- Recently, Jen and I were teammates
on Hollywood Game Night.
We had such a great time,
you know, we won and all,
but we wanted to play again.
But this time, against each other.
(audience cheers)
All right?
Will you, Matt, do the hosting honors?
- I would be honored.
- Okay, take it over.
- Welcome to the first ever
Hollywood Game Afternoon!
(audience cheering)
- [Matt] It's time to play Where Ya Goin'?
Now, Kelly and Jennifer,
you guys played this game
on the show, and even
though you won overall,
you lost this game.
- Dangit!
- But, let's take a look
at how you guys fared.
- We did?
- Did we?
- Where Barack Obama used to
live and now Trump lives there!
- Chicago! Get out! - No, no!
- What? Hawaii!
- No, it's 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue!
- Oh, The White House!
(laughing)
- It's where the Wizard lives!
It's where the wizard lives!
It's the town where he lives!
- Oh, um, um, The Emerald City!
- Yes!
(audience cheers)
- That was intense and
Kelly I love how you became
a New York cab driver.
Here we go, The White House!
- I was like get out!
- You guys did not win that
game, but today, Jennifer, hey!
- Yes?
(audience laughing)
One of you two will be a winner.
Now here are the rules.
We play one team at a time.
Kelly and Jen, you'll be
the designated drivers
for your teams, the rest
of you will take turns
being the passengers.
Passengers, you need to get your driver
to recognize where you want to go without
saying the name of the location.
- Don't you fail me.
- Your team gets one point
for every correct answer.
You guys got it?
- Yes, got it.
- We have got it.
(laughing)
- Okay, let's keep this
civil here Ms. Garner!
All right, Jennifer,
your team's going first
because you're the guest.
- Yeah, I thought so.
- All right.
(audience cheering)
- So, Jen, and we got your
team, here we go, American
Ninja Warrior, we got Sandy
up here, Gardner Reid,
and Lady Gaga fan Will.
(audience cheering)
- Jennifer has her driving
gloves and hat, she's getting
into character.
Jennifer?
- Yes, sir?
- This is for bragging
rights, are you ready?
(laughing)
- All right, you guys we're gonna put
sixty seconds on the clock,
before you go on I will
show you the name of where
you're trying to go, you
get them to guess.
- Are you guys ready?
- Yes!
- Kelly, keep it civil, this is for fun.
- I'm gonna be cool.
- [Matt] You ready?
- [Jennifer] Yeah!
- Not yet, she doesn't
have her steering wheel.
- Okay, here we go!
- Ready, set, go!
- All right, kids love to
go there, parents like to go
there for Christmas ideas.
- Uh, for Christmas ideas,
to get things, a toy store!
- Yes!
- Nice!
(audience cheers)
- This is a place where
you get your teeth cleaned.
- Dentist!
- Yes!
- Okay! It's like the center
of New York, it's like
where all the big lights are.
- Time Square!
- Yes!
- Wow!
- Place to eat, chopsticks are used there.
- Restaurant, Chinese restaurant!
- Yes!
(audience cheers)
- This is a place where,
uh, you go and get
your, uh, license every so often.
- DMV!
- Okay, it's like in Beverly
Hills, like all the little
dogs are there and it's like
the fashion district area
and it's like uh.
- Rodeo Drive!
- Yes!
(crowd cheering)
- Dogs are there?
- Oh boy, it's on!
- It's a planet um, uh, is it blue?
- Uranus, uh, blue?
- Uh, keep going, I don't know!
- Pluto, Saturn?
- Yes!
(audience cheers)
- You're amazing!
- The cookie monster lives here.
- Sesame Street!
- It's like the opposite of hell.
- Heaven!
- Yes!
- You broke the law,
you're going behind bars!
- Jail!
(audience cheering)
- We did not get the last one.
The last one does not count!
(audience cheering)
- Jennifer.
Jennifer?
- Yes?
- That was really good.
That was really good.
- The super sweet Jennifer
Garner was screaming
answers like her life depended on it.
You got nine points!
(crowd cheering)
Nine points!
Team Kelly hass to get
ten correct to win it.
You guys ready?
Kelly, can you introduce us to your team?
- Oh my God, I'm so excited!
Can we just play?
Yes I can, no.
- The two of these guys are
huge fans, and they know
ten answers, and they
will have Kelly Clarkson
defeating the legendary Jennifer Garner.
- You got your hat on?
Okay, I don't know if
you can steer that way.
- I'm just nervous, okay?
I'm just nervous.
It's gonna happen, let's do this.
- [Matt] Are you ready Kelly?
- I'm driving.
- She's driving.
Are you guys ready?
- Sixty seconds on the
clock, nine answers is
the score to beat, and we begin now!
- Go! Where are you going?
- Uh, to pump iron.
- To pump iron? The gym!
- Yes!
- The song that everybody
sings at the weddings.
- YMCA!
Get out!
- Where are you going?
- It's a place in Tennessee where every
singer wants to sing.
- Nashville, The Grand Ole Opry!
- Yes!
(audience cheers)
- Where are you going?
- A burger place on the East Coast.
- What?
In-n-Out?
No, Five Guys?
- It's a color and
royal people live there.
- What!?
- It's the opposite of black
and the Queen would be there.
- White Castle?
- Okay, I don't go there.
- Everybody goes there in Italy to take
their picture next to it. Sideways.
- Oh, oh, the Leaning Tower of Pisa, go!
- Where are you going?
- All the old dead cars go
here, you pick out pieces.
- The Junkyard, bye!
- Where are you going?
Where are you going?
- Uh, I'm going to hit nine
yards, uh, I'm going to
put a ball in a hole.
- Golf club, golf place, go!
- Where the Pope lives in Italy.
- Rome, bye!
- No, no, the smaller
place, the smallest country
in the world. Everybody goes
there to pray, The Vatican.
Shnikies!
- Next, pass, pass!
- It's what you're doing,
you're doing it right now!
- A talk show! Posting, and I'm awesome!
- What's it called?
- No!
- [Blonde Woman] No,
you, what's your name?
- [Matt] I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- The Kelly Clarkson Show!
- We're getting reports right
now, the judges are looking
at the tape, Jennifer and
Kelly, come on up here.
We need to look at the tape here.
Now, there was some
stuff that was going on.
- Where the heck does the Pope live!?
- We like to keep it above
boring here, Kelly, the last
answer to the show.
- Matt!
- Was your show.
- I'm Southern Baptist.
Jesus lives in my heart!
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
- With that,
Being in good sport is part
of it, and it's your show, which is
why Jennifer, you won!
- Yay!
(audience cheering)
- Jennifer!
- Now, Kelly, losers stay on this side.
- Yeah, losers on this side!
- Winners over here!
Jennifer, what does it mean
now establishing yourself
as one of the great game
players on the planet?
- I'm just so proud.
(audience laughing)
I'm just so proud to be
with this amazing team
and I look forward to
being on Kelly's team
again instead of against her.
(audience cheering)
- There it is Kelly.
- This was a game for the
record books, and that's
why we want to thank
everyone who played Hollywood
Game Afternoon, I'm Matt Iseman.